[Music]
foreign hello there you're watching the
Press preview a first look at what's on
the front pages of the morning's
newspapers as they arrive it's time to
see what's making headlines with the
daily mirrors political editor John
Stevens and the deputy comment editor of
the Daily Telegraph Annabelle denim
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight let's take a look at
what is on some of those front pages
we'll start with the front page of the
Metro you're next that's uh comments on
the arrest of Peter Murrell the husband
of the former Scottish first Minister
Nicholas sturgeon is part of the
investigation of the smp's finances the
Scottish paper the national points out
that Mr Merle has been released as
inquiries continue
The Daily Telegraph leads with
suggestions that the arrest of Mr Merle
may have been delayed until a successor
had been chosen for Nicholas sturgeon
or the Daily Mail asks whether this was
in fact the real reason she resigned
although she has already firmly denied
that
according to the eye there are safety
concerns that have led to a pause in the
building of new smart motorways in
England
the guardian carries an investigation
into the finances of the royal family
claiming that the king and Lake Queen
took more than 8 billion pounds in
profit derived from land owned by the
family
a top advisor to president zelenski has
told the Ft that Ukraine's government
could be willing to discuss
russian-occupied Crimea if Ukrainian
forces make it to the border of that
region
and the Daily Star tells us that see
anemone is still capable of learning
despite not having brains
which I guess is good to know a reminder
now that by scanning the QR code that
you see on screen during the program you
can check out the front pages of the
papers while you watch along with us all
right well as I said we're joined
Tonight by John Stevens and Annabelle
Denham for a look cats those front pages
John Annabelle good to have you both
with us let's crack straight on and
we'll go north of the border for the
front page of the national now and they
managed to get this front page done
after it was announced that Peter
Murrell had been released and uh let's
start with you Annabelle
quite a day for the SMP
indeed some quite extraordinary scenes
there and Peter Morrell on the cover of
the national uh not necessarily looking
like somebody who's just spent the day
being grilled by the police
um as the national uh leading with he's
been released without charge pending
further investigation into the smp's
finances of course the police could hold
him for 12 hours without charging him it
would be unlikely in any instance for
the police to have a clear-cut case
after at that point uh they've made
clear that they are still investigating
um but really just quite an
extraordinary uh story and extraordinary
scenes not like any scenes I've seen
before here in Britain
um you know then all sorts of questions
that are going to be coming off the back
of this
um you know was this a factor in
sturgeon's decision to stand down uh
with the result of the leadership
contest have been different had this
happened a few weeks earlier let's not
forget that
um Kate Forbes secured 48 of the vote
you know this is a story that is going
to be ongoing for some time and I think
going to prevent present a lot of
challenges when it comes to contempt of
court because while uh the media might
be very careful in the choice of
language and the way it covers this
story there's no guarantee that people
on social media will be doing the same
and I can imagine that there will be
some Amistad sleuths out there trying to
do some investigations of themselves but
no it's it's really the end to what has
been a pretty staggering day
um for the SMP and the country
absolutely right let's bring up the
front page of the Scotsman John and just
discuss we've saw some moving picture of
it there and on the front of the
Scotsman they've got that uh forensics
tent set up outside the house which uh I
just added to the sort of extraordinary
scenes that we uh were witnessing
outside um the home shared by Nicholas
surgeon and Peter Merrill
yeah I mean a really extraordinary
scenes that tent that massive tent
outside they usually free at the sites
of magazines rather than kind of uh
context Financial investigation like
this and then you're showing the footage
there the police coming in and out there
were footage of the police with Spades
in the gardens searching a shed in the
garden and they're more police in
Edinburgh where the s p headquarters
isn't you know we were looking at the
national front page there just now and
they were going in on how Peterborough
was being released I think that is the
most positive spin you can possibly put
on this story obviously the big thing is
that he was arrested in the first place
and who knows where the police
investigation will go in the next few
months but this is absolutely massive
for the s p we know that they've kind of
been such a dominating force in Scottish
politics led by Peter Murrow he's been
the chief executive since 1999. bigfoots
in Scottish politics behind the scenes
and then obviously Nicholas sturgeon was
the first for nine years they've done
phenomenally well in elections
particularly since that 2014 Scottish
independence referendum which was
obviously lost but ever since then
they've done so well in elections it's
been so hard for the late party and the
Tories they've been nowhere near them in
the polls all of the electricity
completely trounced all of their rivals
and now things seem to be falling apart
there seems to be a real change going on
there seems to be a tectonic ship and
you look at those polls in the last
couple of weeks since Nicholas surgeon
said that she was standing down and
they've already started to shift and you
can see why the labor party and
kirstarma who if he is going to get into
Downing Street he really doesn't need to
improve his party's performance in
Scotland and pick up some of those seats
that it had lost north of the Border
they're going to be really hoping that
this isn't just a temporary blip for the
s p that this is a game changer that
really puts labor back in the paint back
in play in Scotland yeah and animal
let's let's look at the front page of
your paper because this sort of
speaks I guess to um some of the
concerns some of the questions that now
will be raised over the resignation of
Nicholas sturgeon following what
happened today and just talk us through
some of this reporting here
sure um so essentially police Chiefs in
Scotland are now being asked uh coming
up to some pressure to reveal
um if they faced pressure to delay the
arrest of Nicholas surgeon's husband
Peter Morrow until after a replacement
uh was found for the outgoing Scottish
first Minister
um I think there'll be all sorts of
questions over whether it was a factor
in Nicholas surgeon's decision to stand
down uh as first Minister was that
decision prompted by prior knowledge of
the investigation
um as John says this is you know really
adding to the turmoil that's being felt
in the Scottish national party
um let's not forget that a couple of
months ago Marlon sturgeon were a power
couple
um and the party had survived
allegations and Scandals in the past but
it had done so with strong leaders and
what has fundamentally changed now is
that you have Johan Yusuf coming in
after a pretty bruising leadership
contest with it claims that perhaps he's
not the efficient political operator
that his predecessors have been and that
the SNP May struggle
um to ride this out but of course you
know like I said on the cover at the
telegraph really pressing on
um the fact that uh you know and the
fact that moral had to resign of course
straight away
um Midway um during the leadership
contest
um by then it was too late to change the
vote but had he been arrested then
perhaps that might have had some uh
political ramifications
um certainly the scenes today will do
and you know I think fortunate in some
ways that it's a while before there will
be another election I mean the
suggestion always was of course during
that um leadership contest that Amazon
Youssef was uh sort of the establishment
the the top of the snp's chosen
candidates so those questions will will
of course be asked and John
um Nicholas surgeon said at the time
when she resigned she said it
um when questioned later that
outside influences you know the things
that were going on around her had no
influence over her resignations you know
she sort of run out of juice in the tank
um do you think that stands up now we've
seen the way this is playing out
I think she's going to face big
questions about that we heard from her
today from her spokesman saying that she
had no knowledge of what was going to
happen today in advance of it and it
should be willing to help with the
investigation in any way she can but I
think there will be suspicions about
what on Earth has gone on here did she
have thinking of what was about to come
when she did make that shock
announcement that she was going to stand
down and that Alice Bell says the timing
is really interesting here coming so
soon after the Handover of power from
Nicholas sturgeon to Hamza yusa and you
look at if this had been a couple of
weeks ago if the arrest had happened
just before uh what that contest was
still ongoing it might made quite a
difference because as you say comes
Yusuf put him positioned himself as kind
of the heir to Nicholas sturgeon he
described himself as the continuity
candidate and in the end that race was
very tight he just won it
52-48 against Cape 4 talks and you think
it wouldn't have taken much to happen
differently in that contest for it to be
a different result so I think yeah it's
definitely a difficult day today for the
s p and for Hamza Youssef as he said
today but I think part of him will be
signed a relief that this has happened
now rather than when that leadership
contest was ongoing yeah perhaps I guess
now he's got to deal with the mess that
will ensue in the mess that his party
May well face all right guys let's let's
move on from that of course Peter
tomorrow has been released without
charge pending further investigation
let's just bring up before we go to
break the front of the financial times
if we can hear uh Annabelle and let's
just talk through this reporting here as
um president macron and Earthly
Wonderland go to China to speak with Xi
Jinping
um the Ft reporting that's a senior age
to Vladimir zelensky uh suggests the
country could be ready for talks
yes that's absolutely right so Splash
across worked after the headline that
Ukraine is ready for Crimea talks with
the Kremlin if it's counter-offensive
succeeds
um you know I I have my um doubts over
over this
um the Ukrainian scenario has uh for
quite some time now being clear-cut it
plans to or when the plan to expel
Russian troops from every inch of its
territory uh that included Crimea and
the self proclaimed uh donbass republics
that were annexed by Russia um Ukraine's
president zelensky has repeatedly made
clear his ultimate goal of bringing all
his countries land including Crimea
under kiev's control he sees this as
integral so you have to ask where this
change of heart could have originated
from and why they would go ahead with
talks when the momentum certainly seems
to
um be behind them um Keith you know
hoped that it's counter-offensive will
make Headway South and sever a land
bridge between Russia and forces in
Crimea so you know I mean take this at
face value but but I do have my doubts
uh over that it will certainly be
greeted with some relief
um by the West because in Crimea there
is no obvious military solution and
there is a real concern that if Ukraine
presses into the region then that could
back Putin into a a corner that could
lead to him going for the nuclear option
so we'll we'll see how things unfold
particularly with this counter-offensive
absolutely enjoy and with Putin meeting
with um lukashenko and also sort of
stationing uh nuclear ready aircraft in
Belarus recently that sort of fear that
uh the Crimean Peninsula could be the
trigger for Putin to use those tactical
nukes it's very real
yeah and you know countries like Britain
have been very keen when people at the
Prime Minister have been asked what is
the kind of what is the solution in
Ukraine what is the kind of position
we're going to end up with they very
much have publicly said that that is up
to Ukraine what Ukraine kind of wants to
go for is what the West will back them
on but you look at this FTP say quotes
from Western officials in there who do
raise these concerns that if Ukraine if
Kiev does try and push back to those
original borders and take back Crimea
that yeah that could be something that
escalates this war and does persputin
into using nuclear weapons yeah I
appreciate the analysis John Annabelle
more from you guys later do stay with us
all right plenty more to come we'll be
discussing uh what's being described as
an eye-watering amount of money that the
royal family reportedly makes from Land
do you stay with us for that after this
short break
[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome back you are watching
the press review uh with us to discuss
the morning's newspapers are John
Stevens from The Daily Mirror and
Annabelle Denham from The Daily
Telegraph let's get right back into it
John Annabelle good to have you still
with us and we'll go to the front page
of the Guardian if we can now guys and
uh bring this up reveals the guardian
tells us Royals took 1.2 billion in
private income from Estates John would
you make of this reporting
well you can see one of the gardener
running this story we're obviously now
in the countdown until the coronation
it's a few weeks to go and obviously for
a long time the monarchy has been
incredibly strong in the UK when the
queen was on the throne and there
weren't that many people suggesting that
they wanted a republican to get rid of
her but obviously there have been
questions raised as we have the
transition of power from the queen to
King Charles about should the Rome
family continue to exist in the same way
that it has for decades I think that's
why you're seeing this reporting now but
this issue isn't particularly new
they've obviously added all these things
up and adjusted it the time and found
that over more than 70 years of the
queen being on the throne but if you add
up all these different bits all these
different years together you get this
big sum of 1.2 billion pounds of money
that they've got from these uh the duchy
of Lancaster and the duchy of course
yeah they possibly will lead some more
questions about how exactly are those
Estates tax the um the funny don't pay
corporation tax or capital gains tax
on the money they make from those
Estates and they're a question about how
exactly are those Estates run they're
kind of they're not they've run like
companies but they're not companies the
money goes privately to the head of uh
estate to the royal family rather than
to the public purse so yeah it's not a
particularly new issue but you can see
why it's coming up now with the
coronation only a few weeks away yeah
you'd have to delve quite deeply into
the article to find out the time span
over which they're they're coming up
with this figure I mean but Annabelle
the question the the paper raises
whether some of those profits you go to
the public instead should say the royal
family in response to this said that the
uh figure was speculative
yes I mean my view is that you know most
of this is nominal wealth that can't
really be touched uh by them and is tied
up with the trappings of the monarchy
and you know even if we were to take all
of their entitlements away uh who would
really be any better off a few billions
do not amount to much when spread over a
population of 67 uh million people and
that's even assuming you could liquidate
Royal assets such as palaces so I think
it's all very well doing these
investigations and doing this reporting
and bringing up what the guardian
concedes as a Century's old debate ahead
of the coronation but in terms of the
practicalities of what can be done
um from discovering the precise sums of
money I think I think the answer is very
little I think you might be right okay
before we go to break because we have
one short time unfortunately let's look
at the eye and this is a story about
smart motorways I do love these things
uh just opening up the hard shoulder to
make an extra Lane but apparently
because of the lack of safety of losing
the hard shoulder Annabelle no more
smart motorways are going to be built
no NLB interesting to see how the public
responds to this because polling seems
to suggest that the public loathe smart
motorways but equally the public don't
are not big fans of traffic congestion
um which the smart motorways are
supposed to help alleviate by opening up
um the hard shoulder
um you know motorways in general are
pretty safe they account for far fewer
casualties than you get on Rural and
Urban Roads despite
um the high speeds on them and smart
motorways
um have fewer casualties than normal
motorways but I think more of those
casualties are fatal so I think really
you could spin the data on Smart
motorways however you chose but it seems
that the government has come to a
decision uh that they are causing more
trouble than they are worth and they are
indeed uh costly um so which you see
knackers is looking at scaling about the
scheme now unfortunately John I can't
get your comments on this because we
have run short of time but uh you like
smart motorways yes or no
absolutely
depends if you're stuck in traffic on
one all right John Adam I do appreciate
your time this hour more from you later
on all right let's take a look what the
weather's got in store